On October 1st, four new agreements came into force in child welfare,
customary care, kinship care,
voluntary and family agreements.
These are agreements that families can enter into with child welfare
and they are done collectively
with parents input on where the children should go.
This is a means of keeping children with their families
in their communities and in their nations.
This is just one of the things that we're doing
to decolonize child welfare.
These agreements are important because, one,
parents don't lose their parental rights over their children.
And 2,
where traditionally families are not given the financial resources,
families are now entitled to financial resources
to help care for the children in their family.
So why are these agreements important?
And why do they have to be in care
when they have perfectly good family,
extended family at home? My understanding of customary and kinship care
is something that we've always done.
I come from a very large family from blood vein.
My grandmother and grandfather had 23 children,
residential schools,
my aunts or uncles that may have fallen into that social difficulties.
Then my grandparents stepped in and raised my cousins.
But it was normal. It was normal.
There was no child welfare agencies that interfered.
It was how we were raised.
We take care of one another.
We're moving away from the colonization aspect.
We're going to be able to see
the fact that we're able to help families
support the original bio families
that Are in need. The grandmothers would love it.
They're taking care a lot of their grandchildren,
great grandchildren, and doing it without financial support.
So this will help us be able to put in beds,
put in clothing, put in groceries,
and even get the, the kids to do social activities,
cultural activities. It just opens up a whole gamut,
whereas before, there wasn't support like that.
This changes everything. First of all,
I wouldn't have had my frontal rights taken away.
I had to go to court. First of all,
it started out as a voluntary placement agreement. My,
I was in depression and I didn't have treatment for depression.
And then they had these rules of
a voluntary placement agreement was for 6 months.
But if your children have been in care for two,
two years, then they automatically became permanent works.
It enables us to have input to our own children.